[Applaus]
[Musik]
der krieg in der ukraine ist noch lange
nicht vorbei aber er ist mit sicherheit
in eine neue phase eingetreten nachdem
russland seine streitkräfte aus der nord
ukraine zurückgezogen hatte
konzentrierte sich nun auf seine neue
offensive im osten noch immer werden
viele ukrainische städte mit raketen
beschossen und viele von euch werden
denken dass es gleich noch zu früh sei
über den wiederaufbau des landes zu
sprechen doch nach drei monaten krieg
ist klar dass sich der konflikt nicht so
entwickelt hat wie es der kreml
ursprünglich geplant hatte der
russischen armee ist ist nicht gelungen
die kontrolle über einen großen teil der
ukraine zu übernehmen alles deutet
darauf hin dass zumindest der westen und
die landesmitte nicht in putins händel
fallen werden und aus diesem grund
machen sich einige leute bereits
gedanken darüber was nach dem krieg
passieren wird so zum beispiel johannes
hahn seines zeichens eu kommissar für
haushalt und verwaltung die ukraine
braucht nach der russischen invasion
einen neuen marshallplan
was die russen seit ende februar in der
ukraine angerichtet haben und noch immer
anrichten ist die verheerendste
zerstörung und verwüstung europas seit
dem zweiten weltkrieg deshalb erscheint
es als sinnvoll über eine art marshall
plan zum sprechen eine investition in
höhe viele milliarden euro eine große
hoffnung für die leidgeplagte ukraine
dieser plan würde aber auch eine große
chance für den westen darstellen denn
die wirtschaftsmacht der liberalen
demokratien in ein land wie die ukraine
zu locken das zweitgrößte auf dem
europäischen kontinent würde einen
volltreffer direkt ins tor des kremls
darstellen
[Musik]
die ukraine ist mit sehr fruchtbaren
böden gesegnet und mehr als 40 millionen
einwohner gut ausgebildete und noch
nicht überall theater bevölkerung es
würde sich also lohnen der ukraine dabei
zu helfen wirtschaftlich und
rechtsstaatlich voranzukommen und es
viele private investoren so zu
ermöglichen in der ukraine zu
investieren der in diesem video werden
euch verraten wie viel es kosten würde
die ukraine wieder aufzubauen die fragen
lauten also über welche zahlen reden wir
hier konkret woher könnte das ganze geld
für den wiederaufbau ukraine kommen
welche lehren können wir auch den alten
marshall-plan ziehen natürlich werden
wir heute all diese fragen beantworten
und zwar wie so oft in dem wir zuerst
einen kurzen blick in die geschichte
werfen
der marshallplan
[Musik]
jeder denkt dass die vereinigten staaten
den marshall-plan gleich nach dem ende
des zweiten weltkriegs ins leben gerufen
haben das war jedoch nicht der fall der
krieg in europa endete im mai 1945 und
erweitert paaren wurde erst anfang 1988
von us präsident harry truman genehmigt
die wahrheit ist dass die alliierten
1945 in betrieb waren die gleichen
fehler wie haben ende des ersten
weltkriegs zu beginn der vertrag unter
hatte deutschland so harte bedingungen
auferlegt dass diese die junge zweite
deutsche demokratie erstickten nun
schließlich so aufstieg der
nationalsozialisten führten aber es gab
einen mann in den vereinigten staaten
der aus der geschichte gelernt hatte die
rede ist von general george marshall
damals außenminister in der truman
regierung
porsche war davon überzeugt dass ein
wirtschaftlicher aufschwung in europa
für die usa von großem vorteil sein
würde der krieg habe den wirtschaft und
bevölkerung der vereinigten staaten so
eine außergewöhnliche industriellen
einstellung geführt und er hatte dem
land auch die vollbeschäftigung gebracht
diese in friedenszeiten aufrecht zu
erhalten stellte jedoch eine große
herausforderung dar die us unternehmen
mussten weiter exportieren können doch
wer sollte ihre produkte kaufen wenn die
europäischen länder nach sechs jahren
krieg völlig zerstört waren auch diese
frage kannte marshall die perfekte
antwort die subventionierung des
aufschwungs europa
das ziel war also den usa an den großen
und stabilen absatzmarkt für ihre
produkte zu kreieren im grunde genommen
eine statistische politik die darauf
abzielte dass die unternehmen nach ihrer
rückkehr von der kriegswirtschaft so
wenig arbeiter wie möglich entlassen
mussten und einer der wichtigsten
aspekte war 90 prozent des
marshall-plans waren nicht rückzahlbare
hilfen aber das hatte und es hat ja auch
nicht nötig denn die europa verteilten
dollars würden ja wieder durch den kauf
seiner produkte in die heimat
zurückkehren und zwar permanent und mit
ordentlicher rendite im ersten jahr
wurden 60 prozent des marshall plans für
lebensmittel ausgegeben nach und nach
wurde mehr in maschinen die
wiederankurbelung der industrie und den
abschluss der wiederaufbauarbeiten
investiert letztendlich wurden
schätzungsweise 30 prozent der
marshall-plan mittel für rohstoffe und
halb verarbeitete waren weitere 30
prozent für lebensmittel und düngemittel
20 prozent für maschinen und fahrzeuge
und 15 prozent für treibstoff ausgegeben
[Musik]
der marshall-plan biete auch einen
politischen zweck er war perfekt in die
truman doktrin eingebettet die politik
von präsident schon wenn besagte dass
die vereinigten staaten jedes land der
welt wirtschaftlich und militärisch
unterstützen sollten um die ausbreitung
des kommunismus und des sowjetischen
imperiums einzudämmen
viele von euch werden jetzt einwenden
aber wenn es von pensionen und
kostenloses geld im überfluss gibt
besteht auch immer die gefahr von
korruption misswirtschaft und
verschwendung nun in washington dachte
man auch in dieses problem und stuft die
idee eine autonome agentur die den
prozess überwachen sollte bevor sie das
geld freigang dabei wusste man dass eine
gesunde kombination aus autonomie
vertrauen und kontrolle der richtige weg
ist keine zentrale planwirtschaft aber
auch kein absolutes laissez-faire jedes
land konnte selbst entscheiden wie es
die gelder des marshall-plans verwenden
wollte aber zuerst musste es mit der ece
darüber sprechen und ein paar
mindestanforderungen garantieren und es
zeigte sich diese lösung war genau die
richtige
in den vier jahren des marshall-plans
erlebt europa das höchste
wirtschaftswachstum seiner geschichte
die industrieproduktion stieg um 35
prozent die landwirtschaftliche
produktion übertraf das vorkriegsniveau
bei weiteren europa hatte zwei
jahrzehnte nie dagewesenen wachstums vor
sich und dieses wachstum kurbelte den
privaten konsum und die privaten
investitionen an deutschland erlebte
sein wirtschaftswunder wird dass wir
bereits ein video gedreht haben dass ich
euch natürlich hätten oben rechts und in
der beschreibung oder den video verlegen
werde falls ihr es noch nicht gesehen
habt solltet ihr unbedingt nachholen
denn dort beraten wir euch auch die
anderen schlüsselfaktoren der
wirtschaftskraft deutschlands darunter
auch so einige die eher weniger bekannt
sind und euch überraschen werden denn
der marshallplan allein war nicht der
architekt des aufschwungs in europa aber
er hat zur politischen und
wirtschaftlichen stabilität ist alten
kontinents beigetragen
in einer turbulenten zeit legen kalten
krieg waren seine vorteile sicherlich
weitaus größer als die sonne kosten und
ich weiß was ich jetzt fragt das ist ja
alles schön und gut aber wie viel hat
das ganze denn eigentlich gekostet nun
der schaltplan kostete 13 milliarden
us-dollar wir sprechen hier von zwei
prozent des damaligen us
bruttoinlandsprodukts und ganz europa
wieder aufzubauen was meint ihr war dass
er viel oder eher wenig weckt eine
sekunde darüber nach der die große frage
ist nun ob er heute bereit während eine
solche anstrengung für ein land wie die
ukraine auf uns zu nehmen natürlich
können wenn die kita zu ignorieren dass
sowohl in großbritannien als auch
frankreich welche die meisten mittel aus
dem marshall-plan damals erhalten haben
letztendlich historisch eine sehr starke
verbindung zu den vereinigten staaten
hatten aber bei der ukraine geht es um
ein land das die meisten bis vor vier
monaten weniger interessiert hat als das
privatleben von will smith vor der
großen ohrfeige sind wir im westen also
bereitet den wiederaufbau der ukraine zu
bezahlen über wie viele nullen reden wir
eigentlich genau das werden wir uns
jetzt ansehen
[Applaus]
[Musik]
die bilanz des krieges
um es klar zu sagen die ukraine war
schon vor dem krieg das erste land
europas und warum war sie so arm nun
darüber haben sie natürlich auch ein
eigenes video gedreht das ich euch
verlinken werde aber während die ukraine
im januar 2022 schon einen schritt vor
dem abgrund stand ist jetzt noch einen
schritt weiter oder vielmehr einen stoß
weiter die russen haben das ganze land
quasi von der klippe gestürzt und die
wahrheit ist solange der krieg andauernd
ist sinnlos schadensschätzungen
vorzunehmen weil die schäden weiter
wachsen werden so sieht sich moskau
durch fortschritte ihrer offensive im
donbass wieder ermuntert auch wieder
kiew anzugreifen trotzdem wagen einige
experten zumindest ein paar schätzungen
bezüglich der bereits eingetretenen
schäden so zum beispiel der präsident
der weltbank david marx
die weltbankgruppe hat die erste
bewertung der materiellen schäden
vorgenommen sie beziffert die kosten für
gebäude und infrastruktur also die
reinen kosten auf etwa 60 milliarden
us-dollar wobei die wachsenden
wirtschaftlichen kosten für die
ukrainische wirtschaft noch nicht
berücksichtigt sind
die hälfte dieser summe entspricht den
kosten für die wiederherstellung der
beschädigten infrastruktur gesprächen
von 28 milliarden dollar schäden an
straßen brücken häfen bahnanlagen und
stromleitungen
hinzu kommen 20 milliarden dollar
schäden an wohngebäuden die direkt
zerstört wurden und solche liegt kurz
vor dem einsturz stehen andere schäden
erreichen nicht so hohe beträge sind
aber von großer bedeutung für die
zukünftige lebensqualität der ukraine
der wiederaufbau von 200 einrichtungen
des gesundheitswesens würde weitere zwei
milliarden dollar kosten wo die
instandsetzung von schulen und
bildungseinrichtungen würde ebenfalls
ein paar hundert dollar erfordern aber
moment mal denn wie der präsident der
weltbank tote ist dies nur der physische
schaden den wir beziffern können laut
dem ukrainischen premier minister
deshalb werden die tatsächlichen kosten
für den wiederaufbau wesentlich höher
sein
der bisherige analyse hat gezeigt dass
sich die direkten und indirekten schäden
aufgrund des krieges auf mehr als 560
milliarden us dollar belaufen und wenn
wir diesen krieg nicht gemeinsam beenden
werden verluste noch dramatisch
ansteigen
diese zahlen deren etwas höher als die
eines teams des londoner centre for
economic policy research diese nennen
eine sehr breite spanne von 200 bis 500
milliarden dollar aber was bedeuten
diese beträge eigentlich wenn wir sie in
globale und historische relation setzen
nun der marshallplan kostet die usa die
gesagt umgerechnet 2 prozent ihres bip
und das wären heute etwa 450 milliarden
dollar allerdings sind heute im
gegensatz zu 145 die usa nicht die
einzige starke volkswirtschaft die eine
solche hilfsleistung erbringen könnte
auf alle westlichen verbündeten verteilt
liegende unterhalt eines halten prozess
ihrer gps also beispielsweise nur eines
bruchteils der verteidigungshaushalte
und dieser vergleich ist alles andere
als weit hergeholt denn eine starke
stabile und sichere demokratische
ukraine wäre eine der wertvollsten
beiträge zur sicherheit europas die
frage lautet also ist der besten
wirklich bereit diese rechnung zu
bezahlen ist ihnen das alles wirklich so
viel wert nun genau das dann wir jetzt
unter die lupe nehmen
tabula rasa
[Musik]
im jahr 1991 waren die ukraine und polen
zwei sehr ähnliche länder beide hatten
gerade den kommunismus hinter sich
gelassen beide hatten etwas 40 millionen
einwohner und beide hatten ein ähnlich
hohes pro kopf bip doch von diesem
zeitpunkt an wird das vergleich zwischen
diesen beiden ländern extrem schwierig
seht euch mal diese grafik an
[Musik]
da habt ihr jetzt also der einzige
sektor in dem die ukraine erfolgreicher
war als polen die die abschneiden beim
eurovision songcontest was also haben
die polen besser gemacht und was hat die
ukraine firma sitzt der unterschied
besteht darin dass in polen lag bronze
an die macht kam der nicht zuhörte das
kommunistische regime zu zerschlagen und
sich entschieden für demokratie und die
liberalisierung der wirtschaft
einzusetzen auch darüber haben wir ein
schönes video gedreht das ihr nicht
passen sollte nun zurück in die ukraine
denn ganz anders als in polen lief es im
östlichen nachbarland ab die ersten
politischen anführer der unabhängigen
ukraine waren nichts anderes als
ehemalige apparatschiks der
kommunistischen partei der sowjetunion
typische wendehälse aber irgendwie dann
doch nicht konsequent wenn der halle
sich genug auf jeden fall haben seitdem
die unterschiede zwischen den beiden
ländern immer weiter zugenommen bis zu
jenem extrem das wäre heute erleben 1995
hatte polen bereits den größten teil
seiner wirtschaft privatisiert die
ukraine hatte noch nicht einmal den kauf
und verkauf und landwirtschaftlichen
flächen liberalisiert mit anderen worten
sie befand sich im kindergarten des
kapitalismus der aufstieg polens verlief
so rasant dass es im jahr 2004
schließlich bereit war der europäischen
union beizutreten und heute sind die
polen das ist drei mal reicher als die
ukraine aber die preisfrage lautet ja
könnte die ukraine ein neues polen
werden und das ist keine frage an radio
jährige waren denn die antwort lautet ja
ganz real nicht nur im prinzip aber
dafür müsste sie sich europa noch weiter
ernähren und sich endgültig vom
russischen und sowjetischen erbe
distanzieren das betrifft nicht nur die
politik und die handelsbeziehungen da
ist es schon geschehen sondern den
gesamten charakter ihres
gesellschaftlich politischen systems
was ich damit meine nun das ukrainische
arbeitsrecht zum beispiel stammt aus den
70er jahren als das land noch teil der
sowjetunion war die beiden größten
banken des landes befinden sich in
staatsbesitz die liberalisierung des
verkaufs und kosten landwirtschaftlichen
flächen wurde erst vor zwei jahren
beschlossen und die korruption grassiert
in allen bereichen des staates auch nur
in der zeit unmittelbar vor dem krieg
eine interessante frage lautet daher
könnte der krieg nicht zu genau jenem
ruck in der gesellschaft führen und jene
kräfte mobilisieren welche endlich die
errichtung einer wirklichen modernen
ukrainischen zivilgesellschaft
ermöglichen denn der krieg müsste nicht
nur die infrastruktur des landes
zerstören könnte auch das ganze geflecht
aus besitzstandswahrung in korruption
mit sich reißen
es ist klar dass es noch ein langer weg
ist um die produktion in diesem land auf
eine tägliches maß reduziert aber es
gibt hoffnung den sälen ski und seine
verbündeten sind immerhin die ersten
politiker seit ende der sowjetunion
welche schon vor dem krieg wegweisen
entscheidungen für die ukraine umgesetzt
haben die das land endlich in eine
bessere zukunft geführt hätten hierzu
zählten massive investitionen ins schul
und gesundheitswesen und infrastruktur
welche das erste mal in der geschichte
der ukraine auch zu qualitativ
hochwertigen ergebnissen geführt haben
anstatt in den taschen der oligarchen zu
versickern so gute neu gebaute straßen
wie die in den letzten jahren
entstandenen kannten die ukraine vorher
nur aus dem ausland und ausgerechnet
diese wurden nun wieder vor den
russischen panzern verwüstet alles in
allem waren die zukunftsinvestitionen
vor dem krieg für das land ein
deutliches zeichen dass es den ski erst
damit man die ukraine aus ihrer dauer
misere heraus zu führen nicht umsonst
haben wir ihn zur jahreswende denn diese
politiker wort für den politiker des
jahres 2021 verliehen ja wie sich nun
gezeigt hat war ist eine goldene wahl
denn auch in einem anderen punkt hat er
alles richtig gemacht er hat alles auf
den beitritt zur europäischen union
gesetzt denn um es klar zu sagen wenn
die ukraine es schafft alle maßnahmen
umzusetzen welche die voraussetzung für
den beitritt zur eu ermöglichen bedeutet
dies dass sie sich in die richtige
richtung bewegt aber nicht nur das diese
würden auch eine sehr wichtige
geldquelle für den wiederaufbau
darstellen hierzu hilft ein blick nach
polen in den ersten 15 jahren seiner
mitgliedschaft in der europäischen union
hat polen nicht weniger als 160
milliarden euro an eu geldern erhalten
natürlich ist die eu kein garant dafür
dass nicht viel geld in korrupten
kanälen versickert siehe unsere videos
zu diesem thema trotzdem wäre es
sicherlich besser die finanzierung des
wiederaufbaus längstens unter gewisse
internationale kontrollmechanismen zu
stellen und die ukraine dadurch zu
weiteren reformen ihrer staatlichen
strukturen und wird integration in
europäische standards zu zwingen
schließlich wie es auch bei marshall
plan eine gesunde kombination aus
autonomie vertrauen und kontrolle den
weg zum erfolg und aber wieder gesehen
haben braucht die ukraine ja viel näher
als das vorhin haben wir von über 500
milliarden gesprochen woher könnte also
der rest komme nun genau das werden
jetzt ansehen
[Musik]
die geschichte wird von den siegern
geschrieben
die ukraine hat bereits einen store für
den wiederaufbau des landes eingerichtet
er ist dabei in vier verschiedene unter
force eingeteilt einer ist auf die
reparatur der zerstörten infrastruktur
ausgerichtet ein anderer auf der
erfüllung der finanziellen
verpflichtungen des landes und die
begleichung seiner schulden der dritte
auf die unterstützung von kleinen und
mittelständischen unternehmen um die
normalität im privaten sektor wieder
herzustellen und der vierte in der
modernisierung des landes denn die
ukraine hat einen sehr interessanten it
sektor mit gut ausgebildeten fachkräften
und schon vor dem krieg hatte lynskey
auf diesen gesetzt wir wollen die
ukraine in ein land das start-ups
verwandeln wir gehen davon aus dass der
technologie anteil am bip bis 2025 von
vier auf zehn prozent und damit auf 16,5
milliarden us dollar ansteigen wird was
uns zum größten tag hab europas machen
wird natürlich stammt diese aussage aus
der zeit vor dem krieg aber die absicht
seines dies ist klar und die ukraine hat
das zeug dazu und die talente ihren it
sektor schnell wieder aufzubauen und
seien wir mal ehrlich die ukrainischen
gehälter könnten für westliche
unternehmen sehr attraktiv sein mit
anderen worten belege und gute
arbeitskräfte für europäische und us
amerikanische technologie fördern die
unter eklatantem arbeitskräftemangel
leiden gut aber die ukraine wird zu
ihren aufbau noch mehr geld brauchen
viel viel mehr geld und woher könnte
dies noch kommen nun nach der auffassung
es aber auch der eu und der usa ist die
antwort klar aus russland kiew drängt
darauf das eingefrorene vermögen der
russischen zentralbank des russischen
staates und seiner oligarchen für genau
diesen zweck zu verwerten aber zum
jetzigen zeitpunkt wirft dies einige
sehr offensichtliche probleme auf
denn einfrieren ist das eine aber
enteignung etwas ganz anderes falls
diese nicht nach rechtsstaatlichen
prinzipien verläuft könnte sie die rolle
von dollar und euro als
weltwährungsreserven gehen frage stellen
denn wenn die usa und ihre verbündeten
das vermögen eines staates so einfach in
eigenen könnten könnten länder wie china
oder saudi arabien und viele andere
beschließen das ist alles andere als
sicher ist ihre reserven in dollar zu
halten und was das privatvermögen der
oligarchen angeht das problem ist dass
sich die russen seit jahren auf eine
solche situation vorbereitet haben und
anders als es vielleicht den anschein
hat nicht so viel vermögen beschlagnahmt
werden konnten
die schweizer behörden geben zb 8
milliarden dollar an theoretisch ist das
nicht schlecht aber es ist ein
kinkerlitzchen wenn man bedenkt dass
schätzungen zufolge in schweizer banken
mehr als 200 milliarden dollar an
russische vermögen liegen
[Musik]
allerdings ist die oftmals gescholtene
schweiz trotz all dem immer noch der
einsame spitzenreiter deutschland
welches er als großes paradies wird die
geldwäsche russische oligarchen
italienischer mafiosi und arabische
clans gilt bisher lediglich 143
millionen euro beschlagnahmen können in
spanien in die notare der regierung um
neue gesetzliche maßnahmen dass sie der
meinung sind dass sie nach dem
derzeitigen gesetzen nicht gegen die
russischen oligarchen vorgehen können
und portugal nun alles was wir über
portugal sagen können ist dies portugal
fred ein russisches konto ein auf dem
242 euro lagen ein weiteres problem ist
das ist ich um maßnahmen handelt die das
privateigentum verletzten es ist klar
dass russland als staat den in der
ukraine eingerichteten schaden aufkommen
muss aber inwieweit ist es gerecht dass
privatpersonen dafür zahlen sollten
europa und die usa dafür ihre eigenen
rechtsstaatlichen prinzipien verletzen
das gibt zu denken denn es wird ein
präzedenzfall geschaffen von dem man nie
weiß wo er enden könnte und wie ihr
dabei wäre es nicht das erste mal dass
sehr harte friedensbedingungen einen
noch größeren konflikt auslösen es ist
also klar dass die verwendung russischer
mittel zum wiederaufbau der ukraine ganz
klaren und anerkannten internationalen
standards kooperationen sprechen muss
und diese rechtlichen grundlagen werden
gerade jetzt konsequent und schritt für
schritt geschaffen die jagd auf
russische vermögen ist nun ganz legal
eröffnet
[Musik]
in einer veröffentlichung der eu
kommission heißt es dass das vermögen
von personen und einrichtungen die
straftatbestände der gemäß artikel 83
des vertrags über die arbeitsweise der
europäischen union beginnt in zukunft
wirksam eingezogen werden könne in
diesen ersten schritt geht es also darum
dass verstöße gegen die eu sanktionen in
die liste der eu straftaten aufgenommen
werden können gemeint sind damit
natürlich eine reihe von der eu benannte
oligarchen mit welchen ihrer vermögen
durch unterstützung von und verwicklung
in die kriegsmaschinerie russlands eben
auf kriminelle weise verdient haben auf
dem weltwirtschaftsforum in davos
kündigte die chefin der eu kommission
von der leyen die gründung einer
wiederaufbau plattform für die ukraine
an damit diese sich wieder aus der asche
erheben können dabei sollte man nichts
unversucht lassen einschließlich der
möglichen verwendung russischer
vermögenswerte wie sehr idee soll nun in
einem soeben vorgelegten
gesetzesvorschlag der eu umgesetzt
werden durch die eingeforderte diesen
reserven der russischen zentralbank
angezapft und einer neuen bestimmung
zugeführt werden könnten
falls das diesen reserven von insgesamt
585 milliarden us dollar wird allerdings
nicht die volle summe für die bezahlung
von schäden zur verfügung stehen das
liegt daran dass russland 22 prozent
dieser summe im eigenen land als gold
hält 14 als renminbi in china bunkert
von weitere fünf prozent in
internationalen institutionen hält auf
welche die alliierten bisher keinen
zugriff haben zieht man diese beträge ab
verbleiben rund 350 milliarden us dollar
verteilt werden könnten
in der vergangenheit wurden reparation
nach ein mit krieg von dem land gezahlt
dass die aggression ausgelöst hatte in
den ersten beiden weltkriegen war dies
deutschland es musste hierzu jedoch mit
waffengewalt gezwungen oder gar besetzt
werden dies wird im falle russlands aber
nicht nötig sein da viele gegen russland
verbündeten länder ja bereits die
kontrolle über uns lassen in diesen
beständen haben zwölf prozent der
reserven liegen zurzeit in frankreich
zehn prozent in deutschland weiteres
hinaus sind in japan und 7 prozent in
den usa während der rest auf viele
andere kooperierende länder verteilt ist
diese tatsache bedeutet dass die
reparationen diesmal von russlands
selbst quasi vor finanziert wurden und
das ist ein einzigartiger umstand denn
jetzt geht es eigentlich nur noch darum
eine völkerrechtliche grundlage zu
finden damit diese staaten die
eingefrorenen mittel als schadensersatz
für die ukraine verwenden können also
schauen wir uns diese doch mal an
[Musik]
gemäss wo es recht hat russland in
großem umfang und nachweisbar
vorsätzliche unerlaubte kriegshandlungen
begangen dieser tatbestand umfasst nicht
provozierte gewalt gegen andere staaten
und ihre bürger und verlangt als
konsequenz dass der aggressor als
absolutes minimum für das menschliche
leid todesfälle und sagt verlust des
schadens leistet im dezember 2005
verabschiedete die generalversammlung
der vereinten nationen eine resolution
welche die doktrin der vorsätzlichen
unerlaubten handlung bekräftigt in
diesem opfer von
menschenrechtsverletzungen nach
internationalem recht eine recht auf
wiedergutmachung zu spricht in dieser un
resolution werden die mitgliedsstaaten
aufgefordert nationale programme zur
wiedergutmachung und sonstigen
unterstützung der opfer für den fall
eines berichten dass die für den
erlittenen schaden verantwortlichen
parteien nicht in der lage oder nicht
willens sind ihren verpflichtungen
nachzukommen und da es als ziemlich
sicher gilt dass russland zumindest
unter dem regime putin nicht bereit sein
wird diese verpflichtungen zu erfüllen
könnten andere länder die jetzt
russische reserven halten eine eigene
völkerrechtlich legitime task force für
die wiedergutmachung der massiven durch
russland begangenen
menschenrechtsverletzungen einrichten
[Musik]
als erstes muss diese task force ein
verfahren zur erstattung der kosten für
humanitäre hilfe asyl und um und
wiederansiedlung entwickeln die bisher
von den europäischen ländern getragen
werden die ukrainische flüchtlingen
aufnehmen diese könnten über 50
milliarden dollar betragen zweitens soll
von kilb betroffene ukrainische bürger
für den verlust ihres eigentums
entschädigt werden werden die
entschädigung für 11 millionen
ukrainische familien im durchschnitt
20.000 dollar pro familie beträgt würde
sich die gesamtsumme auf 220 milliarden
dollar belaufen hinzu kämen potenziell
dutzende von milliarden für
invalidenrenten und um hinterbliebene
für den gewaltsamen tod ihrer
angehörigen zu entschädigen zu guter
letzt muss der wiederaufbau finanziert
werden sobald der krieg beendet ist bis
dahin würden diese mittel treuhänderisch
verwaltet ein betrag von mehr als 100
milliarden us dollar wäre realistisch
dieser steigt jedoch mit jedem weiteren
klicks tag weiter an
[Musik]
zur umsetzung der maßnahmen wird es noch
erforderlich sein dass die parlamente
der teilnehmenden länder der
operationskosten fonds weitreichende
befugnisse gewehren auf regierungsebene
werden da die zentralbanken angewiesen
die mittel an eine abwicklung
institution zu überweisen weil sie die
technischen voraussetzungen ihre
verteilung manager zum beispiel an die
bank für internationalen
zahlungsausgleich alternativ könnte aber
auch die das land anteilige zahlung des
vereinbarten zeitplan vornehmen
[Musik]
[Applaus]
es ist möglich wenn auch eher
unwahrscheinlich dass die verfügbaren
350 milliarden dollar durch die
finanzierung aller drei komponenten
dieses plans erschöpft werden vor allem
über die beteiligten länder beschließen
einen teil der reserven im rahmen eines
friedensabkommens an russland zurück zu
geben dies könnte einen anreiz für eine
mögliche neue führung in moskau
darstellen infocus corporation und
frieden zu schließen allerdings scheinen
im augenblick die aussichten dass
russland auch nur einen cent seiner
blockierten reserven wieder sieht
äußerst minimal zu sein auch wenn
starten wie das in der eu zunehmend
isolierte deutschland ihre russischen
oligarchen kumpels noch nicht ganz
fallen lassen wollen und vor allem ein
kleines land besonders stark bockt
ungarn aber über den spezialfall des
viktor orban und seine verstrickungen in
die russische kriegsmarine werden wir
schon bald ein ganz eigenes video drehen
vergesst also bitte nicht das abo und
bitte auch nicht dass glücklichen uns
auf gar keinen fall zu verpassen auf den
fall seit jetzt erstmal ihr mit eurer
meinung an der reihe denkt ihr dass
europa die ukraine unterstützen und
ihren wiederaufbau finanzieren sollte
welche chancen sehen zum beispiel für
die europäische wirtschaft sollten
außerdem auch russland seine oligarchen
dazu gezwungen wäre für alle schieben
ihre invasion zu zahlen wie immer sind
wir schon auf eure beiträge im
kommentarbereich gespannt ich hoffe dass
euch dieses video gefallen hat und ihr
vielleicht auch etwas hat gelernt habe
was ja geneigt wir uns freuen nun
vergessen ist aber mit glücklichen und
keines unserer videos mehr zu verpassen
natürlich freuen wir uns auch jederzeit
über eine spende von euch mit iris hält
dieses projekt weiterzuführen den paper
link dazu findet ihr wie immer in der
beschreibung in dem video was gut und
bis bald
[Musik]